[موسيقى]
اسمي هو انا مغروم ببيروت وببيوتها
الحلوين
[موسيقى]
انسحرت بالجمال المدينه
اللي هي كانها ضيعه بس كبيره
وهيدا الشي انا توقفت عنده حسيت انه لا
لازم هالبيروت تضلها
موجوده وما تنتسى لانه بيروت كانت بتتنفس
من البحر كل شي بيجي لبيروت بيجي من البحر
وكان كلها خضار وشجر وجنينات
وارميد وقناطر وعصافير وهوى نظيف
فهذا الشيء انا خلاني
انسى بيروت كيف صارت هلا
ولحتى نقدر نعيش ببيروت مثل ما كانت ما
بنقدر ببيروت مشان هيك جمعت قطعها الحلوين
من بيوتها الحلوين واخذت بيروت تعيش معي
بالبترون وهلا هون بيروت موجوده بهذا
البيت
بمتحفه بتراسل القديم
[موسيقى]
كل شي شفتيه بهذا البيت كان بهدول البيوت
مزهريات كله اتجمع من 100 بيت راحوا من
بيروت
وصورتهم وين كانوا هول القطع وين صاروا عن
هون بهالمتحف
هذا هو المتحف مثلا هول الثلاث قناطر
كانوا بهالبنايه بزعل البلاد
صاروا هيدا الواجهه الحلوه كنت بالاشرفيه
انتقلت لهون محلى الجديد
بس يصير عند المتعهد ورشه جديده انا ازعل
بالاول انه دعان هالبيت هيك يروح وبنفس
الوقت كنت انبسط لانه اوكي ما بيقدر يضلوا
هيدا البيت ببيروت بيقدر يكون بمطرح تاني
[موسيقى]
كنت اشتري القناطر تلاتاتهم مثل بعضهم
واجهه كامله بلكون كامله عمدان كاملين
[موسيقى]
كنت انا اشتريهم
وجمعهم هون بالارض وبعدين اخدت قياساتهم
وعمرت على اساسن هيدا البيت اللي عم
بتشوفوه هلا بكل تفاصيله ولا غلطه
[موسيقى]
بس يوصل للزوار لهونه
باول شي عندهم انتباه انه هذا البيت اكيد
مش معمر هلا كانه هون البيت صار له 200
سنه
وببلشوا يفوتوا وينسحروا بالجمال اللي
سحرني انا
وببلشوا يطلعوا على الضوء والهوى والشمس
والالوان
ومنهم يتذكروا
جدودهم منهم بتذكروا البلاط منه بتذكروا
التفاصيل والنمليه
[موسيقى]
صناديق سته لهلا راح تشوفون هن صناديق
السفاره هذول الوحيدين اللي بقوا من
عائلتنا تيتا كان بيتها ببيروت ما بقى من
بيتها الا السندي
[موسيقى]
انا مبسوط وهذا بيتنا قبل ما يكون متحفنا
ومتحف لبيروت
واخذ حقه منيح من من الحب اللي العالم
فرجتني اياه
ومن الاهتمام العالم فرجته لتراسل بيروتي
لانه انا حققت حلم كثير عالم عبالهم كانوا
يعملوا
[موسيقى]